i've said it all week long as soon as
the
titans and the ravens were scheduled to
play each other in the playoffs and
these guys can attest
i reached out to both of them on text
right away because when the nfl network
started
this is what the titans rival ravens
rivalry was all about
it was about eddie george one of the few
members of the 10 000 yard rushing club
of his illustrious
playing career and ray lewis pro
football hall of famer from the
baltimore ravens good to see you guys
hey
blessed be seeing my views
rich i keep telling eddie how many times
am i going to see you this week man
oh this isn't the first this isn't the
first
i'm tired of seeing him i was tired of
seeing him on the field
every everywhere i was the ball he
number 52 was right there
and he was there to hit you with bad
intentions
reporting to say hello we're not
pressing
i just i just knew i just knew i always
knew
if i let you get to my secondary one
gonna be good
i wonder what it was like if you walk me
through it you know you you
you go first here uh ray when you
knew that you were playing the titans
because this was back in the day when
you saw him twice uh
twice a year too yeah but rich man look
honestly
like me and eddie we do it all the time
but we we go
back even further right before they came
right became tennessee you know we
started this robbery when it was houston
you know and for us to start this in
1996
we met in 1995 played with play ball
american kodak all-american and then we
had this little rivalry
you know in college and just so happened
we ended up in the
same conference so when we started going
at it man
we became really great friends i think
at the pro bowl
97-98 when we first went to the pro bowl
and actually i was getting every drink
that eddie wanted i mean
rich rich i tell this story all the time
man eddie went to the pro bowl and this
one people didn't even know who the
baltimore ravens were
right and uh eddie walked into waikiki
and they was like oh and rich
i stood behind 400 people for three and
a half hours
on autographs and the rivalry begins
right
no it rains absolutely right you know uh
and i do recall we had we started the
competition in the backyard of
the agent that was courting both of us
and
uh started off with a friendly drinking
game
and you know how when you see masters
smashers
and then it led to us going to the
backyard shooting paintball trying to
hit
a target and then it led into reign
talking well if you wasn't he said hey
if i saw you in college right now i'm
fresh off the heisman he says man i will
snap you in half
and ray at the time was he had a cast on
his foot
and he was about 208 at the time again
i'm like boy
hey you should lighten it
and that's where it all started
and i tell you what you know uh ray's
absolutely right a lot of our rivalry
began when i was in houston he was in
baltimore
when we did played in front of
absolutely nobody nobody
there was six the the coleman protocols
was in place in 96 in houston
there was nobody in there yeah and it
was competitive
yeah you know ray was a a young rookie
at the time
very hungry uh on a baltimore defense
that was kind of complacent
and he was really trying to change the
culture you can sense that
here was a team you know won four ball
games we played in the last game of the
season memorial stadium in baltimore
place pack and i'm like this is the last
game
we're not going to the playoffs uh he
may he
he's going to pro bowl i'm going to the
pro bowl let's just get to this game and
just call it a day it's not going to
no i mean goal line stands it was like
as if it was
for the game-winning touchdown the super
bowl and
it was a matter of fact that's that's
where he knocked it
out of me i'll never forget that
i came up the gut and all of a sudden it
was
lights out next thing i know i'm coming
to on the sidelines
and steve jackson our defensive back
came up he kept walking by me like
looking at me like what happened what
happened he says man you don't want to
know
all i said was that ray look before i
didn't finish the citizen ray lewis
knocked your ass
out i said no no no
and that's and that's that's where it
all began man they got and it got
really nasty thereafter when both of our
teams became
yeah they yeah yeah so it's special to
watch it now it's really special
um me and him talk about it all the time
um
we talked about it last year the year
before every time we grew to play each
other
yes yeah we call it tell them the phone
say here we go again
again and before we get to the here and
now i do
still just want to live in the past a
little bit because you know again
what i said at the very top it's true
when the nfl network began it was o3
and that was just after you guys were
placed in
different divisions right then and there
but it was
several years two times a year sometimes
three and and the two of you guys would
be the ones
meeting in the hole like the number of
times we're like well this quarterback
against that quarterback
you know but they're not on the field at
the same time it really was
the two of you what was the the defining
moment i think for both of you guys in
that battle
for both of you which one i'm gonna tell
you
um i never forget this rich like
you know tennessee was always from 96 97
98 99
we weren't good we weren't good so the
only battle
was me and eddie for me right it was
only me and him
and it was interesting because every
time we would see each other
when we saw each other off the field it
was like hey man meet me at the bar
let's hang out right the pro bowl and
it's like
but then when we got on the field it's
like this switch and we had this
ultimate respect for each other but we
had this ultimate competitive spirit
that said i'm not losing to him and i'm
not falling on my back
right that was the thing like you know
back in the day like you could not get
ran over that was a big thing in our
neighborhoods right
and i'm like myself and so i think it
started happening right in 98.99
and i never forget it um i'm editing and
went on that run
and i think what you had 403 carries
that year something like that
mm-hmm and it ran on this run man rich
and i'm sitting there
and i'm like what if the freak is going
on like this team
is thriving and i'm calling ozzie and
i'm like aussie how is tennessee better
than us
and this is crazy and to see eddie
take that next step right to go to the
super bowl
against the rams in 99 and they're down
and told you this story a thousand times
and i'm sitting where i'm sitting and i
see this guy pulling your helmet getting
this end zone
and this girl jumps up she says eddie
george is a beast
rich i got up at three o'clock in the
morning while drinking in
the weight room
[Laughter]
i said god darn it i gotta find a way
to this train this train and uh
and and i think it became i think it
became so personal
if people knew the respect we had for
each other we would meet
and put it in and bow to each other and
and and after the playoff losses i mean
this guy
the respect that we have for each other
we we we beat them in tennessee and the
first person
before i see the media before i'm
halfway dressed
eddie walks in in a white silk matrix
outfit
and
and he walks in and he says bruh
man to a man go do it go in it
you're the better man and i'm telling
you from that day man it was just like
this brotherhood was formed and yeah and
rich
and that was that was a time
like for me because we were i think we
were the number one seed that year
going into the playoffs uh in 2000
and you know we knew
that whoever won this game between us
and baltimore
that nobody else the super bowl was that
day
yeah we knew that yeah we we're gonna
see the raiders she's gonna smash them
we do it didn't matter who you put in
front of us
it was gonna be lights out that's how we
were built like that
yeah and that loss for me
was the toughest loss i've ever
experienced it was like as if somebody
died in my like in my family the closest
member to my family
died because you you put everything out
there it was it was very personal there
were some things
said between the organizations we did
not like each other
the head coaches did not like each other
the fan bases
hated each other if you died on the
field that day
it was good britain's gonna get him out
of here it was
it was no it was no love lost okay
so so when when ray picked the ball off
in the end it was defining moment
because it was as if
he that's when his career really took
off because all the stuff that he went
through that offseason we're not going
to go into that
yeah to to watch him rise
above that and to become the ultimate
player that he became i mean he
he was a man on the mission there was
nothing that was going to stop
him from winning a super bowl that year
here he was on the cusp possibly his
career
everything on the line and then to watch
that to to watch his team rally around
him not just his team
but his whole city so to me that was a
defining moment
where i watched ray lewis become a real
man
and become the hall of famer that he is
today
because he made some really choice
decisions that he was going to operate
this way and do things his way as a
matter of fact
back in the day when he made a phone
call used to get these voice messages
and this music and during that time
it was he used to have luke prior to
that or some other songs on
on the voicemail but i called him and it
was a song called a change is going to
come
that's uh that was it sam cooper i'll
never forget this so it goes deeper than
just
on the field with us yeah we love each
other like brothers off the field but in
between the white lines
yeah i die if he killed me that day it
was it was okay
wasn't there a time where you you guys
were barking each other i mean that's
the most famous one where you may on the
sideline and you're just in each other
no but it's every play rich listen i'm
telling you i tell editors all the time
i'm and i'm not exaggerating this if you
go back
and you watch ali and frasier if you go
back and watch sugar ray and hagler
if you go back and watch those classic
battles rich if you
ever went back and i told editors that
if we don't sit down
and go back from 96 and just take me and
his
plays on how many times we met
one-on-one in the whole rich i'm telling
you i i
and he tell you this i used to go in the
weight room my trainer will tell you
he's to say what's on your mind this all
season eddie george
eddie george i don't care it does not
freaking matter
like this dude is god darn it
i get it i get it right and and you got
to remember this
this old school football they running
the ball 42 times
right that's minimal that's
minimum right with a fullback two tight
ends
there's no tricks to the game and that's
why i think the respect of
because we knew what they were going to
do they were going to run the ball
right when they got an i formation i'm
like here we go
and we got to dance and so i think the
respect started to happen
even even when that pick happened they
came to baltimore earlier that year and
we lost it in 15 to nine
grand mcgaffey picked off that ball if
you remember going to the end
we lost to them 15 to 9 and i'd never
forget coming in
in the locker room and marvin was like
defense i was like mark i don't wanna i
don't wanna talk man all the coaches get
out
all the coaches get out and in the end i
mean rob what's gonna tell you this
story man i'm sitting there and i'm like
man
freak man how this this this guy man
this freaking guy come
beat us in our city and that's when i
think
me watching film clicking peyton manning
eddie george and tom brady
was the three like people masters of the
game
that made me study and take my game to
another level from a mindset
it was i mean it was paige man and then
tom brady from a
physical mentality of how you have to
play the game
it was eddie george and the george stood
six three 245 pounds
and then george was thumping he coming
downhill
it was it was me saying here we go again
and so man i'm telling you me and this
dude talk about this all the time man
but
i don't think there's ever a greater
back of a rivalry
between a linebacker and a running back
that we had
in our careers and and crazy enough
definitely for the first five six years
i mean
team wise and what they were doing
against us he won most of those we just
had a lot of personal one-on-one battles
really eddie george here on the rich
eisen show let's turn it to the
here and now because we just had a great
chat about
the old days of youtube guys and now i'm
sweating up in here now he got me he got
me ready to roll
great i love it and because ray you were
talking about how
it was old school football with eddie
you coming downhill and
coming and coming with 40 some odd
carries a game if
or touches the game and and the titans
have an old-school
workhorse monster of a back who gets
stronger as the game goes on
now a 2 000 yard season back to back
washing titles in in in derrick henry
who won and done the one-seeded ravens
last year and you know the ravens got
class campbell specifically i think
for this game i mean
so i'll say to you eddie is how do you
think this plays out what do you think
happens
in this matchup this weekend yeah
well you know it seemed like the rules
had reversed um
there was a time when baltimore had our
number and we could not
figure out a way to beat them um no
matter what we did we could be up
in the fourth quarter to find a way to
win the game and i
kind of feel the same way now that the
titans kind of had baltimore's blueprint
in terms of how
to um uh minimize the great plays that
lamar jackson has against them um they
allow him to get
from 20 to 20 but at 20 and then the red
zone
they've mastered the game plan to where
they they're kicking field goals versus
um versus scoring touchdowns so
defensively i think
they've really figured out how to stop
baltimore how to slow them down
he's not allowed that running game to
get going jk dobbins is going to be a
key factor in this game
if he's able to get off it's going to be
a problem
for for tennessee so the guy to stop the
head
you understand that lamar's gonna make
his plays but they can't allow them to
be consistent
on first down a first second down with
the run game now for tennessee
i i don't think there's a defense in the
league
built to stop tennessee's run game
meaning personnel wise unless you pull
out
the 2 000 ravens with ray lewis sarah
goose and sam adams
that's probably the only defense that
can probably stop
derrick henry and there's there's no
there's no there's no scheme
there's nobody there because once they
lay on you
and once they the office of line creates
a lot of scrimmage you give that man 18
inches of daylight and i'm going to talk
to speak from gail saves 18 inches of
daylight that's all he needs
you can take a 90 you can take your 56
you can take it two yards it doesn't
matter
and he doesn't get discouraged by taking
the zero
uh zero gains the hard twos the hard
threes
he's going to get a scene he's gonna
take advantage of it i don't think
baltimore can handle it for four
quarters yeah
look i i'm a and i'm a fight for him
and i'm on the baltimore side but i just
honestly think rich
that derek henry to me barry henry
should be
the nfl's mvp and this is just me i i'm
i
i i respect the quarterback position
on it to a certain point but what he has
done
from the ground running the football and
the
how big he is and the speed he has when
he gets into the secondary
that second and third level that's one
of the things that people don't
understand
is eddie and i told eddie this because i
told their hearing the same thing
of his stride right eddie's stride was
longer when eddie stride
it was winding back to come
derrick henry keeps his feet really up
under him and he's like a little scat
back so as you see
right he never opens up his stride so
you ask me rich
what will happen this this is what i
think tennessee
interesting enough their defense was
always
just tough they were just tough our
offense always struggled with them
if you watch tennessee now that's that's
kind of died down
just a little they're not as dominant as
they once were in
front seven and and and how you can get
to them even from last year even from
last year and i was just watching this
game i was telling eddie
i was just watching the game on the
network because i got to do some of the
homework on it but
i was just watching the game from the
network perspective and i'm like wow
they don't have him they don't have him
wait a minute he's gone he's gone so as
you see
they're even number wise they've dropped
a lot
baltimore where they picked up at it
they they've become even more creative
with jk dobbins right jk thomas is a
slasher he's a quick hitter
so now you bring somebody like him mixed
with lamar jackson
it makes it real hard to deal with him
but the biggest thing is
they're getting the ball downfield right
they have to get the ball downfield
that's what tennessee has the advantages
with aj brown on the other side
yes i think i think aj brown is in the
same category as julio jones dk metcalf
all of those guys right he is a problem
one-on-one
so how do i think this plays out
honestly
and this almost goes back to our style
football eddie
the last team of the ball wins you know
the team
and and a lot of people say oh man i
hate cliches football i hate when people
please shave me with football
right take the points that you need to
take because every point in this game
gonna matter
yeah there's no fourth down there's no
oh i'm
no i'm not gonna take the three take the
three and i think baltimore this just me
personally
i think from what baltimore has
offensively
what tennessee has lost defensively i
think we gain an
edge but i think where it balances out
is derrick henry you have to have
somebody
on baltimore's side even though you
bring in clear scandal even though you
bring in wolf
you have to have a linebacker or
somebody step into derek henry's chest
if nobody steps into his chest at beasts
get
stronger and stronger as the game go on
and that's what you don't want late
late in november i mean in january
of football what are you saying what are
you saying to lamar
ray i mean this this kid is um
you know dynamic and he's all for two
now
he's one and done twice this would be a
very large
win for him and also another loss that
has a whole off season of wondering
what's going on i mean what do you talk
to him about right
you know honestly honestly and we
haven't spoken you know to
to get into it but you know yeah so i
haven't spoken to him to get into his
head like that you know let him do his
thing
or whatever but you know just from
outside perspective
lamar is going to be lamar eddie said it
lamar is going to be lamar he's dynamic
he's spectacular he's superman
all of those things but lamar needs
help a lot of it to go do what he's
trying to do
and to beat tennessee in tennessee lamar
i'm telling him
um hollywood brown these guys downfield
are gonna have to be
big for lamar they're not gonna be able
to sit there and a lot of these routes
sometimes route right the only deep man
that's going right that's going deep as
hollywood brown if you study them enough
nobody threatens or from the baltimore
side we don't threaten a lot of people
right people aren't afraid of our past
game right we don't have a devante adams
we don't have a dk metcalf we don't have
aj brown
we don't have a person that you have to
double so now they're stacking the box
right so now lamar has to tell somebody
else or the scheme
greg roman the scheme has to get
somebody open downfield so it doesn't
always have to be a long
eight nine play drive yeah so
um before i let you guys go here um
you want to chime in on the topic du
jour of the week about sunday night
football the way it ended
and um you know because this whole
conversation has been about competition
no matter what
you guys were talking about your your
careers
and uh early on you're playing in front
of nobody but it didn't matter to you
so what do you guys eddie you go first
what'd you think of the way sunday night
football
um well honestly you know i didn't have
a chance to watch all of it but just
listening to what happened
um how philadelphia sat some guys down
and kind of gave the game away
and then you know listen you know
coach has his opportunity to do whatever
the hell he wants to do
you know um you don't owe anything to
anybody i mean he gains nothing
by uh winning that game and getting
washington to the playoffs or or the
giants i mean you got to focus on
your building what's in between your
walls so if you decide to say hey you
know what
i've seen enough out of jalen hurts i'm
gonna see some other guys give them a
look
it's so big if the giants wanted to make
the playoffs and dammit they should have
won the games they should have won
yes that's how i look at i mean don't
i'm not going to say oh
uh billy oh you all laid down so we
can't get in i mean you you getting in
on
six game six and nine or seven and nine
i mean
that's not that's not that's not an
attitude of excellence and
if as an organization if i'm the head
coach of the new york giants if i'm
bitching about that
then i have to question the competitive
nature of my head coach in terms of
you know you know are we really going to
complain about how philly didn't let us
into the playoffs well i should be
saying you know what we're on the verge
this is not the product that i want to
see on the field next year let's get to
work
i mean in the story so i'm not buying
all that you know
if you if you wanted to get in the
playoffs you should have won the games
you should to get in
that was the shirt you get in right yeah
yeah i learned that early i learned that
earlier
99 we were sitting there waiting for
somebody to lose
and i never did man i don't like this
feeling this is
horrible like you're sitting there
waiting for somebody to lose and eddie
said it best like
seriously like judge if you're the
giants man win more games
like like you're going through
everybody's going through this
what they're going through but you know
now from the philly side
i'ma tell you this yes tell me about
that one yeah and this from a defensive
perspective
from a defensive perspective rich
every time i put my pads on i put my hat
to win the game
i don't put my pads on to experiment you
experiment
it's freaking pre-season that's when you
experiment
you don't experiment with oh i want to
try somebody
and see what he looks like when my
defense
has given everything they got even with
all of the players
that was out on that defense see and
this is where and i'm telling you this
this is where on the field leadership is
because on the field leadership goes to
him and said you get out there then
if you want to experiment you gonna hit
somebody because what i'm doing you
don't appreciate it
that's philly that is the philadelphia
eagles
that is the that's man that's mount
rushmore's of football heavens
you can't play you can't you can't um
evaluate somebody in that sense of a
game why
because if you take all of those guys
and feel it in philly
and jaylen hurts this young kid the only
reason he was in that game
was because of jaylen hurts you get on
you get on the goal line and it's fourth
down
you know how hard it is coaches make uh
players make plays
coaches make decisions and decisions
determines outcomes of games
it'll never change you don't ever take
points off the board rich
ever not even in pre-season
not if you got someone on the other side
who strap up they strap up and
die for this game rich i die for this
game and you're not gonna tell me
that's like that's like one of my
coaches telling me all right we're gonna
play
a quarterback we you know we really
don't know that much about but
you know y'all keep playing really
that's a problem
that's why i only feel leadership is
crucial and that's why i challenge a lot
of kids and a lot of young men
become a student of the game so you can
have conversations
with your coordinators and your head
coaches instead of just listening to
everything they say
because if you have enough leadership i
don't care who it is i don't care if
this wins i don't care who it is
if you can knock washington out of the
playoffs
you savage your season you save your
season
you see you you send your team out on a
high
instead of going out on this oh what are
we doing now
right now the whole city of philly is
questioning this man philly it's too
rich in football
it's too rich in football to let that go
down the way down and i'm a fan of jalen
hurts and no matter how many mistakes he
made he's a youngster he's gonna make
mistakes the rest of his career but that
young kid has something special
from alabama everywhere he went home
everywhere he went he's a winner
and people love to see him win that guy
that other kid get in there and throw
the pit another kid getting that form of
the
form of the ball really really so yeah
man
look play the game the game with the way
the game's supposed to be played
and that is give everything you got and
put the best men on this
that's what me and eddie george came up
in the best men gonna play
it's not an experiment no more once
preseason is over
yeah guys the best i appreciate taking
the time ray
i appreciate absolutely you be well
happy new to
you and your families enjoy the games
and let's let's chat uh maybe
later on in the the month before the
super bowl we'll talk about it yes sir
you got it thank you buddy all right
thank you you guys
love you man love you guys see you on
friday yeah
i'm seeing you friday again all right
brother
yep hey you watched all the way to the
end
thanks for that watch more right here